- Steering wheel's moving.
Seat belt's fastened.
No one's behind the wheel.
Robotaxis are real, at least
here in Chandler, Arizona,
where Waymo has been offering
fully driverless rides
for more than a year.
Waymo's looking left, Waymo's
looking right. All right.
And in August it expanded
to San Francisco,
but rides here still have
a driver behind the wheel.
The supporting driver does
have hands on the wheel,
not always gripping the steering wheel,
but always hovering around the wheel.
It's an important test for the company,
as it could provide a
roadmap for expansion
into other cities, but the race is on.
General Motors Cruise is
also testing driverless cabs
in San Francisco.
- You could really build a
sizable ride-hailing business
if you set up operations here.
- But rising costs and tech limitations
have slowed driverless car companies down.
So can Waymo, with operations in Phoenix
and now in San Francisco,
pick up the pace and bring its robocabs
to more cities and more passengers?
To find out, we spoke to company leaders,
and yes, took a couple of rides.
(bright music)
We're here at Waymo's
depot in San Francisco,
a city that represents an
important test for the company
as it looks to expand
its service, and well,
it's got a lot of cars.
Waymo's ride-hailing service, Waymo One,
is new in San Francisco, but the company,
formerly known as Google's
self-driving car project,
has been testing here
for more than a decade.
- San Francisco provides
a wide diversity of not only geographies,
but also a diversity of
the kind of interactions
that we'll have on the road itself.
- So you can see, we're in a
little bit of a busier part
of the neighborhood here.
There are cars parked along the right.
There's a truck here, stopped on loading.
Waymo rides in San Francisco, like the one
the company invited "The
Wall Street Journal" to take,
are currently done with
a driver at the wheel.
But the company says it's
the tech aboard its vehicles
that are making the
majority of the decisions.
The tech that I can actually see here,
what are the main components?
- The LiDAR, which is the
360 degree at the top,
while the smaller ones are on the side,
the perimeter LiDAR.
We have cameras, 29 different cameras,
positioned throughout the vehicle,
and radar is a third kind.
And then lastly, within the trunk
is where we have the majority
of our compute systems,
so the systems that take
all those signals together
and combine it, run it
through our software,
to help the car determine
what it should do next.
- All of Waymo's passengers,
or Trusted Testers,
in San Francisco have signed
nondisclosure agreements
that prevent them from
sharing their experience.
Well, except for me.
So right now, Waymo's driving us around
a pretty residential area.
Lots of stop signs. No
stoplights on the route so far.
I think seeing the
supporting driver's hands
hovering and sometimes
grabbing the wheel itself
is providing a little bit of
additional security for me.
Waymo really likes to
stick to the speed limit.
Last week, a Waymo car hit a
pedestrian in San Francisco.
The company said the
vehicle was being driven
by a human driver in manual mode
when it struck the pedestrian,
who was treated for injuries at the scene
and transported to a
hospital by ambulance.
The company said, "The trust
and safety of the communities
in which we drive are paramount to us,
and we will continue
investigating this incident
in partnership with local authorities."
So far, seven companies,
including Waymo and Cruise,
have received permits from the State
to test autonomous
vehicles without a driver.
But Waymo wants to be the first
to offer its service to the public.
How far off do you think
you are from being able to
pull the autonomous
specialists from the vehicle?
- Our current focus is
really continuing to develop
a safe and convenient experience
for all of our riders,
so no specific timelines
to share at this time.
- [Adam] Success in San
Francisco could help provide
a revenue-generating business for Waymo.
Analysts estimate its cars cost $200,000
and it can't yet charge
passengers for rides in the city.
- They don't need to
operate a robotaxi fleet
in a ton of markets
because if you look at
the business performance
and results of Uber and
Lyft, they mostly come from
just a handful of cities around
the world, like 10 cities.
- [Adam] WSJ reporter Tripp
Mickle covers Alphabet.
He lives in San Francisco and,
like many residents there,
has been seeing Waymo's cars a lot.
- They seem to be on a rotation or a loop
in terms of what routes they drive.
- To see what Waymo could
look like in future markets,
we went to Waymo's first location,
a 50-square-mile area
around Chandler, Arizona.
Here, Waymo has pulled the driver support
and riders can now hail
robotaxis themselves.
The wheel is moving by itself.
When did you know it was
time to pull the driver
out of the Waymo here in Chandler?
- We evaluate the
performance of the driver,
the Waymo driver, on a
given operation domain.
We evaluate it against general
features of topography,
geography, weather, and
also specific features
such as the unprotected left turns
and ability to handle a large parking lot.
That is the process that we
used to release our technology
here in Chandler.
(bright music)
- After traveling more than
65,000 miles around Chandler
without a human behind
the wheel, Waymo opened up
its ride-hailing services
to passengers like me,
willing to try.
While there, I spent about an
hour in the back of a Waymo.
We're turning. (laughs) There it goes.
I took three separate rides,
including one in the dark.
Waymo encountered construction,
an emergency vehicle,
(siren wailing)
and took three rights to avoid a left,
though I did experience
one unprotected left turn.
Waiting for intersection to clear,
and it is starting and stopping a lot.
Okay. You may be good now, Waymo.
Ooh. (exhales) All right, we did it.
- [Waymo] Arriving shortly.
- [Adam] Waymo was a defensive driver,
but the experience took
some getting used to.
The biggest hurdle, trusting the tech.
- Trust needs to be earned
and we earn it by our
excellent track record.
And we also earn it through transparency
and really engaging with the public.
- [Adam] Before opening up
its ride-hailing service
to the public,
Waymo published safety data
from its tests around Chandler.
It reported 18 collisions
over a span of about 6
million miles driven.
- None of those collisions
were serious in nature,
but regardless, every single
event is a learning experience.
- Do you have any updated data
since launching the ride-hailing
service here in Chandler?
- And I'll tell you that the
positive trends that we saw
in that first report, where
we evaluated 6 million miles,
has continued through our service.
- [Adam] The company says it
completes hundreds of rides
in the Chandler area each week
and has served tens of
thousands of riders there.
- It's put them at the forefront
of the driverless car effort,
but it's also Chandler, Arizona.
It's not, you know, in 50
states, or much less two states.
It's really in one, you
know, one suburb of Phoenix.
- Waymo's ambitions, however, are greater.
It's now testing in 25
cities across the US,
though the company wouldn't say
where it plans to offer rides next.
What's slowing Waymo down
from expanding to cities across the US?
- It's technology, really.
There's been a realization, broadly,
across the self-driving industry
that their ambitions and hopes of creating
something that was like a computer model
that can be scaled and
dropped anywhere, in any city,
is not totally realistic.
- It took Waymo three years
of on-the-streets testing
before it offered its ride-hailing service
in the Chandler area alone.
What can we draw from that pace
for Waymo's future expansion?
- I don't know if that's a great proxy.
We build on our experience
and our technology
such that it takes us less and less time
to learn the intricacies
and be able to drive safely
and reliably in any market.
- Because of this, Waymo
expects to pick up the pace,
and it might need to.
Cruise has raised more than $9 billion
to support its robotaxi efforts.
Waymo has raised nearly 6 billion.
But just how many riders
will hop in the back
of one of these robotaxis,
remains to be seen.
Ride done.
- [Waymo] We've arrived.
(bright music)